all right we're gonna pull up this uh
this first question uh about switching
jobs should this person take a job with
more pay but fewer benefits or should
they stick with fewer benefits and uh
hold a
lower salary and so this question
specifically states as we pull it up
here
i've recently been looking for a new job
in the hopes of making more money good
goal i just was offered a job that gives
me higher base pay but not really any
bonuses or commission and no guarantee
on work from home once they return to
the office having a hard time
determining if switching jobs would be
worth it here's a breakdown of it i have
been with my current company for 10
years you're being underpaid you've been
there for 10 years you're being
underpaid i do love the company i work
for but i have tried to change
departments before in order to increase
my salary but it's really a lateral move
if i do so this is my current pay and
benefits person gets paid a base of 44k
they get at 10k in bonuses as well as
spiff money and contests from vendors i
make roughly 57 000 a year all right 57k
i get four weeks of paid time off as
well as given the option to purchase an
additional two so i get six weeks total
and three floating holidays i get 500 a
year in employer hsa contributions a six
percent match on my 401k i get to work
from home all week currently and once we
return to the office i'll have to go in
once a week but we've been told from
upper management this is only going to
be the norm going forward since we
proved during the pandemic that working
remotely didn't disrupt productivity
huge for me is i love working from home
and really don't want to go back to the
office my job is not difficult easy job
and i actually have a lot of spare time
so it's just easy and i am comfortable
the new job however i think uh says
something very differently where they
say the new company is offering me the
following 60k so about 16 15 000 more
base pay and 2 300 in bonuses for the
year as well as rsu stock stock alert
that i could cash out at the end of the
year when it invests in the amount of
just under 2 grand bringing my yearly
total compensation to 64 000
so they make 57 in the old job 64 in the
new one they offered three weeks pto
they do not have hsa contributions they
match four percent and they are working
remotely for now but once they return to
the office they say that it might be a
hybrid where they'd be going in three
days a week and working from home two
days per week but it's not guaranteed
and they believe in being in the office
to quote build relationships big
relationships folks over there i've done
the math and it would make much more
each month but i am not sure if the
extra pay is worth losing the benefits i
currently have and i don't quite
understand stock stuff stock stuff
that's a great term i have never done
anything with stocks before it would be
nice to bring home a little more money
but losing my work from home two percent
401k match and no hsa contributions is a
real bummer is it worth leaving a
company i've been at for 10 years for
this offer my sister says yes but my
boyfriend isn't so sure hoping to get
some outside perspective on this thanks
for the help
the classic case
should i be happy or should i get paid
more money
simply if you've been working at the
same company for 10 years you're being
underpaid so you're seeing that with the
market obviously they're willing to pay
you about 10 percent or more uh increase
in pay so you're gonna get paid 10 more
you still have three weeks of pto and
they have a four percent match on the
401k
to me the big question here is not about
is this a better pay package because i
think the pay package is kind of a
no-brainer that this is better
especially when you look at the stock
and depending on the business and does
the stock go up all that kind of stuff
uh it really just comes down to how
worried are you about work from home and
if they were to go in office would you
absolutely hate your life or if they
stayed and allowed you to work from home
a couple of days but you had to go in
the office a couple of days then you
would end up being okay like to me this
is a no-brainer better pay package
because you get more cash and also uh
you've got some stock here where in the
other business you didn't um and even
though the 401k match is a little bit
lower you're not making enough money for
it to be super material yeah um but it
just comes down to work from home i
don't know what do you guys think well i
think it's a a few things right so
you're obviously making more money uh
you've been at the old job for 10 years
so you have to ask yourself hey look if
i've been here for 10 years and they
haven't given me a raise or if there
doesn't look like a promotion is coming
is that ever going to come so that's
certainly there's some kind of uh some
subjective qualities of it that you have
to determine yourself but then you have
to just average the cost of everything
else right so commuting from home that
may cost someone 50 a month it may cost
them a thousand dollars a month it may
cost them more depending on if you need
to take a train if you can drive you can
do all these things so these are all
things that can be uh done with math
right you can just average out how much
it's going to cost you to commute from
home worst case scenario if you have to
go into the office every day you should
look at uh how much you'll make when you
add up all the stock into your salary at
the end of each year you should look at
the 2 difference that you're going to
make on your 401k again it may not be
material but it's something so you
should you should budget that out into
all the things and then once you have it
down on paper uh kind of the exact
amount i'll make here the exact amount
i'll make here budgeting out the
difference between working from home and
not then you just make the decision
based on the pros and cons of one if
you're comfortable with the salary
increase or decrease or staying the same
and then two if that's the career that
you want to stay in or a job you want to
stay in if you're comfortable if you
think that you may get promoted and if
you don't then maybe you jump on the
other one even if it was the same amount
of pay right so i think when you're at
this salary range right here it's not
necessarily always about to pay right
and that's easy to say uh if this person
doesn't need the money necessarily every
month to break even or save money uh but
if they do maybe that's something else
to discuss but in these times uh it's
usually more about kind of the quality
of the job and the position that you're
in and the opportunity for upside right
so there's equity involved that's uh
significant depending on if increases in
value or decreases but they also might
have the opportunity to get promoted to
another job that pays ten thousand
dollars more or twenty thousand dollars
more right so i think it's subjective in
the nature of like you have to figure
out the alternative stuff it's not
always just about kind of just budgeting
out dollars and cents and figuring out
if it makes sense john perfectly said
one thing i will note is his hype man no
it's just perfectly said i appreciate
you john yeah one thing i will note is
um look if you like your job that's a
very big deal right um going to a new
job is scary there's a lot of unknown
factors who you'll be working with on a
daily basis you don't really
like in the interview process you can't
really understand the person's
personality and what they are actually
like as a manager as a boss as a
co-worker or anything like that um so
that's a really big deal to think about
and then
i've said it before that there really is
no job loyalty right if uh if push comes
to shove your employer will let you go
unfortunately in most cases um but talk
to your employer about what your goals
are and see um see if that opportunity
for advancement's there because like
there's nothing worse than declining a
job offer and then in a month realizing
why did i stay here there is no there's
no promotion coming there's no
advancements coming uh one thing that is
really annoying is when your current
employer is hindering your advancements
right if you're trying to
if you make a lateral move you're really
just switching bosses and you're
switching job titles and like the
responsibilities but you're not really
switching like your position in the
company i i'm 26 years old right so i've
seen my friends have gone through those
first five or six years of their career
and
and switched some to switch out some
stay in the same position but at the end
of the day the one thing i think it
comes down to is like you don't want to
switch jobs uh at that point in your
career for a small incremental benefit
salary wise and what i mean by that is
like say you jump for a 5k bonus or a 10
000 increase in salary but then in two
years you get another opportunity or in
another you get another opportunity next
thing you know you're 26 27 28 and
you've already had four to five jobs on
your resume and you've only increased
your salary by 10 or 15 000 so when you
make that jump and you take that risk
and you say hey i'm gonna go make this
jump and figure out uh how to get paid
more you want it to be a substantial
amount of money to where you're not
doing it in two more years or another
year so you're basically saying like get
a big boy bonus well if you're going to
jump right you don't want to find
yourself looking for that nut everyone
always wants more right so you're always
going to be like hey look there's other
opportunities out there i can go do
these certain things you won you want to
be comfortable in your job that's
probably most important
for relative salaries right you want to
be comfortable but then when it comes to
it when you're going to make that jump
you want to make sure it's a large
enough salary increase to where you're
not looking a year later for a five
thousand dollar increase a ten thousand
dollar increase you want it to be
something where you can stay for a few
years and potentially forever right but
you want to be able to stay for a few
years so you don't look like you're just
jumping ship every time you get another
salary one thing that happens a lot with
younger uh people as well when they just
start their careers is they get a job
straight out of college straight out of
school trade school whatever it is um
and then that job for two years and then
they leave and they go do something else
whether it's in the same industry or not
so if you do sales normally i've seen a
lot of my friends right
after two years they look for a new job
they utilize basically hey look now i
have some experience can i get paid more
can i do something more that like i
actually like rather than just hey it
was an entry-level job two things that
people brought up i thought were good
ideas one is you could take this new job
offer and go to your existing employer
and say hey i'm gonna leave because i
got this job offer will you match it so
if you like the job and it's just a pay
thing right uh and you like the work
from home and all that then you can
basically use the new job offer to
leverage it into getting a pay raise but
staying in the job that you're at well
one thing i would say on that too is
like people don't always take into
account it costs companies money to fill
jobs right so if you leave this job for
a three thousand dollar uh increase in
salary you go to them and say hey look i
i'm gonna i got an offer to pay three
thousand dollars more get paid three
thousand dollars more per year if it
costs them if they know that it costs
them 3 500 or 5 000 or whatever it ends
up being especially in this market to go
and fill that job then they're going to
be like all right that's a no-brainer
right especially if they like you the
quality of your work and they know that
you get along with everyone that's kind
of a no-brainer they're not going to
match the benefit base right like if you
go to employ your employees offers but
this one has less benefits so the new
job has less benefits so they're
actually better off on the benefit front
staying and then also it seems like
they'll be happier staying and then if
you can just get that bait that pay bump
then you're good i know someone who
switched jobs and they immediately they
left after two weeks they're like i
didn't like the people i worked with it
was the exact same they were doing the
exact same work they got that which was
that well not too weak i think it was
like a month but they basically realized
they're a look i'm not enjoying working
with these people every single day and
but that's kind of my point right is
like when you're talking about numbers
any
look ten thousand dollars is a lot of
money in certain in certain
circumstances but when you're talking
about salary increases uh for someone at
a certain percent right that's five
percent six percent seven percent a lot
of it comes down to subjective things
right if you value your your co-workers
if you like where you're working out if
the commute is good if your boss doesn't
give you a hard time right so a lot of
that stuff uh can be dealt with or uh is
recommended that you keep it if it's
just a smaller salary increase but if
you can get a 10 15 bump those things
become smaller things on the on the pros
or cons list someone asked how does it
cost them if you leave a lot of ways
yeah it's expensive to find and hire new
and good employees well you gotta one
you have to process somebody out two
then you've got to go post the new role
you've got to do the interviews you know
you've got to potentially work with an
outside agency internal recruiters all
that then you've got to vet people that
takes time and money and then on top of
that you've got to onboard them retrain
them kind of integrate them et cetera so
it's actually a monetary pain but it's
also like an operational pain as well
and then when you're in a tight labor
market what they actually may end up
doing is not being able to fill the role
given what they're paying you because
they know they're underpaying you and
therefore if they want to fill the role
they might have to end up paying even
more money than just what you're asking
for from a pay bump people are giving
away incentives right like they're
giving away uh free things for free
benefits whatever it is they're uh it
costs money to train someone right maybe
you don't like the person as much as you
like the previous person maybe the
quality of their work isn't as good
maybe they don't work as hard maybe they
don't work as many hours right so
there's a bunch of different things that
go go into it and it's extremely nuanced
and we're kind of like just generalizing
it but at the same time you have to take
all those things into account when you
go to leave a job it's not just as
simple as hey i got paid uh five or ten
percent more i'm gonna go leave now
because they're paying me more there's
just so many more things that go into it
and you have the leverage as a current
employee especially in this market where
they're trying to fill jobs and it's
tough to do hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com so that you can
get an account we can get after it
you